a shutdown over new 5d wireless
technology that could lead to major
cancellations and delays at america's
airports airlines say it may interfere
with some types of aircraft a-t-t and
verizon yesterday agreed to suspend the
service around many airports but they
will roll it out elsewhere today chris
vancleave is in denver chris good
morning
well good morning even one senior faa
official told me they expect there to be
some quote bumps today and in the days
ahead where i think you'll see this play
out most clearly the next time there's a
big severe weather event like a big
winter storm airlines are going to be
forced to cancel flights earlier and
likely cancel flights for a longer
period of time but even something as
benign as fog particularly at a major
airport could cause delays lasting for
hours to ripple across the country and
already some international airlines are
canceling flights to the u.s
this morning as a t and t and verizon
are launching their new ultra fast 5g
wireless service nationwide
airlines are bracing for travel
headaches we're going to see some
disruptions there's no question about it
captain joseph depete is the president
of the airline pilots association we
want to be leaders in in the world in
terms of 5g but we don't want to do it
at the expense of aviation safety while
the fcc says 5g is safe the faa is
concerned about interference with
systems that help pilots land in low
visibility and bad weather prompting a
host of flight restrictions if there's
cloud cover if there's rain you can't
use that equipment you can't land
airports at chicago o'hare at atlanta at
detroit this cannot be the outcome
airlines warned as many as eleven
hundred passenger and cargo flights a
day would be delayed diverted or
canceled so tuesday the wireless
companies agreed to two mile buffer
zones around many of the nation's
busiest airports the faa says that will
reduce the worst disruptions but it has
approved just 45 percent of airliners to
operate in all weather conditions where
5g is active airline industry analyst
henry hartevelt this could have a
disproportionate effect
on people who live in mid-size and
smaller towns
where they're dependent on smaller
airplanes that are not on the approved
list delta and other major airlines are
preparing for weather-related
cancellations due to the 5g restrictions
the nation's airports say tons of cargo
shipments have already been impacted
it's a fastening your seat belt hang on
kind of weak
we got a sense for what a 5g delay may
look like and how airlines will explain
it let me show you this from united
airlines they had a flight i was
supposed to fly here from denver to
houston it was showing a three plus hour
delay and the airline was very clear
that they say it was because of the 5g
activation they even included a link
where people could complain to the fcc
and while 5g has been activated in
nearly 40 countries around the world
without an issue the faa is still
verifying about 55 percent of aircrafts
that they have systems that won't
interfere with the 5g system so
these issues could go on for weeks gail
i want to follow the faa guidance on
this one thank you very much chris